I have been playing SCP games for pretty
much my entire channels history this
video is not about those games because
the games are not the origination of
those stories those stories originate
from a website called SCP - wicked net
and that website which is a creative
writing project about these SCP
creatures that website is in trouble to
summarize and I'll get into detail later
but to summarize a man by the name of
Andre Dux in books in I'm probably not
pronouncing that right is a Russian man
who filed a trademark for SCP as a whole
with the Eurasian custom Union and as
far as I know they approved his
trademark which is fraudulent because
there's no way that this person had
anything to with the writing project or
the collaborative effort of all the SCP
s throughout its entire history which
originates all the way back in 2008
maybe even earlier than that that's what
I remember so why is this a problem well
to understand why it's a problem is to
understand a little bit more about the
copyright status of what the SCP
foundation and the SP wiki is I'm not a
lawyer what I do know is what is listed
on the website and what is listed on the
website is what SCP wiki falls under
which is Creative Commons and Creative
Commons is something that allows you to
use the work so long as it's credited
back to the original owner however
anything created based on the SCP
foundation as a whole has to also be
registered under Creative Commons this
means you're derived work must be
released under the CC BY SA so that
other people can use this same license
it is not enough to simply attribute the
SCP foundation this person is trying to
monetize every single piece of property
listed on the SCP wiki in Russia and
what that means by extension if he wins
that fight and gets the trademark he can
also make an argument to get all the
other languages versions of the SCP
foundation and then suddenly everything
that the hundreds of authors have come
up with for SCP wiki every
creature every entity is suddenly all
owned by Andrzej dachshund just for
filing a trademark now I'm making a
summary these things you can read more
detail about this but the bottom line is
they need help and specifically they
need help because legal battles cost
money unfortunately if you love the SCP
foundation if you love the SCP games
containment breach the unity remake the
various other remakes please consider
making a donation to help fight this
fight I'm gonna be making a donation
right now a lot of you guys have
probably found my channel through the
SCP videos you know I owe a lot to the
SCP wiki as a whole and also it's just
great stuff if you've never had a chance
to read this stuff I highly recommend it
in fact I am going to put a link in the
description to the next thing I'm gonna
talk about which is a really interesting
thing done for the SCP foundation that
I'm going to showcase but let me give
this donation done real quick ok so I
have just made a $5,000 donation to this
campaign I think that this is just
outrageous what this person is trying to
do there's so much potential in stuff
like this but it's squandered because
people are trying to be opportunistic
and are trying to like claw thick so
I'll provide a link to this GoFundMe in
the description below there hasn't been
an update to the fight just yet but
these things take a lot of time and we
can only hope that they win because
otherwise it's going to cause a lot of
problems anyway in better news there is
something called the SCP pixel-art
collapse if you've never read the
website of the SCP foundation SCP - wiki
dotnet there are hundreds hundreds upon
hundreds of anomalous creatures objects
entities world destroying things
all of them are fun to read and they are
conveniently made into this pixel art
collab and what this is is a compilation
of the pixel art from the SCP pixel art
collab and their associated SCP articles
not only a graphical representation of
what these scps are and a lot of the
times the scps will have an image
associated with them but this also
covers s ups that don't always have an
image with
and it puts them in a very easy to
navigate very easy to read
you can pick apart what you want now
we're all gonna die now that's scp-096
which is the shy guy where if you see
his face he will come and kill you so I
am sorry but maybe the pixel version
isn't as bad but what makes us so cool
as it's a it's it's it's a way to
enhance what was already great
storytelling and so you know some SUVs
are better than others but there's a
wide variety of the different SDPs that
are available here that you can see
pretty much everywhere yeah that's a
vibrator I've read almost all of these
now and it's opened up the doors for me
to look into SCPs that I never would
have ordinarily read because if you look
at the wiki it's not like a bad way to
read and you can definitely get to
everything that you need to get to oh my
god look at all these SCPs every single
one of these is an article that was
written by a community member
expanded upon you can click on
absolutely any of these this ones oh
yeah this one's the fourth new pot
doctor bright that's actually a pretty
famous one 9 2 3 a useful tool yeah all
of them you know what actually I wonder
are these actually all filled in top to
bottom oh my god they are holy [ __ ] this
is just how much content is on the wiki
oh my God look at that people can't stop
writing oh yeah all of these and all of
these are articles everything everything
is an article everything there are
thousands I thought it was hundreds it's
apparently thousands also this one's a
great one SCP 3000 is I really like it
taboo
whoa that's a highly rated one I've
never read this one
not the point I'm gonna read that later
but what the pixel art collab is it just
makes it easy to consume and it's great
it's just super cool and I just wanted
to recognize the great things that do
exist about you know the SCP foundation
SCP Rock description it's a rock that
makes you procrastinate addendum
probably mimetic or something I'll
finish writing this up later
like Todd it I [ __ ] love it yeah so
if you want to get into the SCP
foundation I actually would recommend
looking at the SCP pixel-art clap
because it makes it real easy it makes
it really accessible I'll put a link to
it in the description below and just
frankly it's it's a good time with that
being said that is the SCP pixel-art
Club and that is the problem that the
SCP foundation is currently going
through Creative Commons probably has
pluses and minuses to it because it may
it probably makes it very hard for
anything like a movie to be made about
the SCP foundation although it would be
really cool if there was if it was done
right and in the right hands I think
there could be a great thing to be made
by someone that really loves the
universe and understands the importance
of it you know the games are all made by
people that just love the stories and I
think that's a beautiful thing
it really makes every single thing that
comes out of it a work of passion like a
passion project it makes people actually
care about how it's represented and how
accurately it's represented they don't
need to dumb it down for like a broader
audience because like it's meant for
those that can really appreciate it and
I think that's that's definitely
something that you can't say about
everything so the SCP foundation is
something to be appreciated and
protected I know this is a different one
this is a like a different cause that I
normally make a video about but I think
it's important
number one it's important for people to
understand how much writing is actually
there for the SCP foundation I didn't
know there was that many and I've been
reading like crazy last few weeks but
honestly it's just you know it's too
important to let it be compromised by
someone who is trying to be
opportunistic and make a trademark that
he does not deserve so links are in the
description thank you everybody so much
for watching if you are a fan of the SCP
stuff then maybe help out if you can
hopefully more SCP content is coming
your way because the SCP unity game is
waiting on a
big update for 0.7 so who knows how
that's gonna be but when it comes out I
will definitely play it it's supposed to
be a big overhaul of the game and maybe
containment breach will be updated
someday I don't know it's still fun to
play so thank you everybody so much and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye